the united states constitution
explicitly calls for copyright and
patent laws to promote the progress of
science and useful arts by authors and
inventors but would getting rid of all
intellectual property laws actually
encourage more creativity and innovation
by inventors writers and artists that
was the topic of a november 15th soho
forum debate held in new york city
stefan kinsella who spent 28 years as a
practicing patent law attorney argued in
favor of the proposition that all patent
and copyright law should be abolished he
believes that government-created
intellectual property laws empower
patent and copyright trolls and powerful
corporate interests while limiting the
free flow of information thus reducing
the rate of innovation and creativity
richard epstein the lawrence a tisch
professor of law at nyu says that our
current system isn't perfect but he sees
copyright and patents as a natural
extension of private property rights and
believes that they should be defended by
libertarians accordingly the debate took
place in new york city in front of a
live audience and was moderated by soho
forum director gene epstein
now
for the main event
the resolution reads and again you're
voted on it all patent and copyright law
should be abolished here to defend the
resolution stephen kinsella stefan
please come to the stage
opposing the resolution richard epstein
richard please come to the stage
if richard could could climb over a
couple of bodies
he will he will come to the stage
and uh yes okay all right don't get too
friendly uh stephanie sit here
get on the far see you want
far far right yes absolutely richard
epstein is no relation to gene epstein
but uh because there are a lot of a lot
of jews name epstein uh and uh but uh uh
we uh now have to close the voting jane
please close the voting and uh stefan uh
you can take the podium which i assume
you'd like to do you have 17 and a half
minutes to defend the resolution take it
away stephanie
thank you very much gene uh it's a
pleasure to be here especially with uh
professor epstein i'm
really grateful you agreed to discuss
this with me you're one of my
intellectual
teachers and
i've learned a lot from you over the
years
the resolution is all patent and
copyright law should be abolished
why i want to briefly say i'm a patent
attorney i've been doing it for about 28
years i've been a libertarian for far
longer than that and
i actually wrestled with this
intellectual property issue because
patent and copyright are types of
intellectual property law i wrestle with
this issue uh all throughout college and
law school and as a young attorney and
around the time i passed the patent bar
i decided that it should all be
abolished
so um
i came to it through a lot of hard
thought and and my 28 years of
practicing has only deepened my my
feeling about this
um the bottom line is these laws violate
property rights they violate freedom of
speech in the press they distort culture
they impede innovation they literally
kill people both copyright and patent
and they impoverish the human race
there's literally nothing whatsoever
good about patenting copyright law
they're complete abominations and they
harm humanity okay they're a mistake
that's why we should abolish them
now what are these laws okay these are
arcane laws that specialists like me
learn about and professor epstein
teaches about
copyright is
uh
protects the right of authors like
creators of artistic works
for original works of authorship like
novels paintings movies for the life of
the author plus 70 years which means the
term of copyright now lasts about 120
130 years in many cases and by the way
originally it was 14 years at the
beginning of the country
copyright law is enforced by injunctions
and by legal protections like statutory
damages of up to a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars per act of infringement
patents
are granted by the state to inventors of
practical devices like machines or
processes
and they last for about 17 years and
they can also be enforced with
injunctions
unless the government takes it back with
what's called a compulsory license which
they threaten to do sometimes
now there are obvious objections to
these laws the first objection is that
they obviously violate natural property
rights because they prevent people from
using their own property as they see fit
copyright in effect prevents you from
publishing a book or singing a song
because someone can use a court force to
stop you from doing it patents prevent
you from making products competing
or even improving on other people's
products
right legally speaking in my view these
laws should be thought of as what's
called a negative easement or a negative
servitude which you guys are familiar
with in the term of a in the form of a
restrictive covenant or a homesteading
association
policy where your neighbors can prevent
you from painting your house a certain
color
so negative servitudes or easements are
fine if they're consented to but these
are not consented to the state just
grants this negative easement which is a
property right so it's a taking of
property it violates property rights
i'm not 100 sure but i believe professor
epstein even agrees with that it's just
that he doesn't think property rights
are absolute
so the idea is that
generally so why would you favor
monopoly privilege grants by the state
that violate property rights protect
people from competition and censor
speech
because they think that property rights
in the free market while generally good
sometimes they fail there's what we call
market failure due to various problems
as professor epstein points out
repeatedly in some of his writing on
intellectual property and in his takings
book
like the free rider problem or holdout
problems or coordination problems so the
idea is that on occasion the state can
identify these problems and come in and
they can do a taking of private property
which is the power of imminent domain or
some kind of regulation and it will
solve this problem and make society
better off and when it does this it
generates a social surplus because it
makes us richer and out of this surplus
you can now compensate the person that
you took
property from so like in the house of in
the case of a building a road you need
to take someone's house to build the
road they're they're compensated for the
fair market value of their house by tax
receipts and everyone else is better off
that's the theory but the point is as
professor epstein points out in his
takings book most government regulations
are takings but they don't make us
better off because they're not solving a
real problem and they're doing that
damage to us all and therefore they're
unconstitutional
under the fifth amendment okay
so the question is
in the case of
intellectual property
why do we why does this logic apply
there
why can you violate property rights in
the name of helping out helping uh
granting a monopoly privilege to an
artist or to an inventor
okay so the idea is that
because of the unique nature of certain
types of products and services that are
intellectually based like if you if you
write a novel paint a painting or if you
come up with a new mouse trap or a new
iphone
it's too easy for other people to
compete with you so generally
competition is accepted and tolerated
you know as a libertarian i think is
generally a good thing but the chicago
people think it's tolerable if
competition is difficult if compensation
competition is too easy then it's going
to be difficult for the first guy to
recoup his investment costs so then
he'll never invest in the first place so
that's the basic idea and this is the
idea by the way behind the
the the copyright clause in the
constitution of the united states which
says
congress has the power
to promote the progress of science and
the useful arts by securing for limited
times to authors and inventors the
exclusive right to their writings and
discoveries so that's where patent and
copyright come from from that clause
now historically the origin of patent
and copyright
come from thought control and censorship
and protectionism
the printing press
threatened state and church control of
what could be printed which led to the
stationers company and eventually and
its monopoly on printing books and then
culminated in the statute of anne in
england in 1710
and the origin of patents lies in
mercantilism and protectionism where the
king would grant open letters or a
letter patent because the word patent or
potenti means open granting someone the
exclusive right to sell a given product
in a region like you're the only guy who
could sell playing cards or sheepskin
pure protectionism that culminated in
the statute of monopolies in 1623
this finally led to the us constitution
authorizing congress to pass similar
laws which we have now
so let's talk about copyright
copyright has its origins and censorship
and thought control so it's no wonder
that's what it still does today
so i'm going to give some examples these
are just
some examples and i'm going to go
through some data in a little bit so the
seminal german silent film nosferatu
which some of you may have heard of and
even seen was deemed a derivative work
of dracula
and courts ordered all copies destroyed
now luckily someone preserved a copy and
that's why we still have it today
shortly before his death the author jd
salinger author of catcher in the rye
convinced u.s courts to ban
publication of a novel called 60 years
later coming through the rye as a sequel
unauthorized and it was a derivative
work and copyright law prevented the
publication of a book
there was one time about
2005 a grocery store in canada
mistakenly sold 14 copies of the new
harry potter book a few days before its
official release
and so a british columbia supreme court
judge ordered customers not to talk
about the book copy it or even read it
before its official release date
copyright also threatens freedom on the
internet which is very serious because
the internet is one of the most
important tools we have in the fight for
freedom to fight state state tyranny
and just a few years ago the stop online
piracy actor sopa was only narrowly
defeated um by by an internet an
uprising on on the internet
uh aaron swartz who some of you may have
heard of was a brilliant young inventor
of rss the technology behind blogging
and podcasting and he was an anti-sopa
activist he uploaded some academic
journal articles to the internet and he
was facing life in prison for federal
copyright
infringement and he killed himself
guiding gilberto sanchez bought a copy
of an unfinished version of the 2009
movie x-men origins wolverine in the
bronx
uploaded to the internet and was
sentenced to a year in federal prison
there was a grad student in britain
named richard o'dwyer who had a website
with hyperlinks to other people's
pirated movies
and the us went after him and finally
got a judge to order him to be
extradited to the united states to face
federal prison
he finally escaped it but his life was
almost ruined and derailed for many
years
in 2011 there's an interesting paper by
law professor john tehranian
where he talks about the how the normal
activities because of the statutory
damages clause of copyright that i
mentioned earlier up to 150 000 per
infringing act um a typical internet
user like an average american law
professor like maybe named richard um
who doesn't who doesn't even engage in
p2p file sharing could theoretically
result in up to 4.5 billion dollars in
liability annually for copyright
infringement
and if you might remember the singer
susan boyle
okay the singer susan boyle from
american idol was prevented for singing
a song because of copyright
now patent law let's take some patent
law examples patent laws rooted in
protectionism so it's no wonder that's
what it does today it protects people
from competition back in 1999 the dawn
of e-commerce amazon had a patent on one
click which was
clicking once to complete an order and
they sued barnes and noble right at the
beginning right before the christmas
season for daring to let its customers
complete a purchase with a single click
by the way these are not abuses these
are how the laws are work and are
supposed to work
in 2008 a patent holder threatened to
use cord injunctions to force ford not
to use various technological safety
measures like active park assist
stability control blind spot detection
and hands-free voice control
so this is another example of how
patents can prevent safety safe measures
from being implemented and can cause
injury or death
and by the way professor epstein's all
in favor of patent injunctions because
after all if the property right you need
to enforce it
even though here's another one even
though the practice of saving seeds
after a harvest
to plant the next season is as old as
farming itself
patents prevent farmers from saving
patented seeds
monsanto even and others even come after
farmers for growing patented crops
just because the wind carried it from a
neighboring farm
back in 2010 there were people who were
literally dying who had fabry's disease
and they could be treated with a drug
called fabrizine made by genzyme it was
in very short supply because it was
being sold in europe for a higher price
no one else could make it because of the
patent another example of how patents
kill people
and for a more recent example some of
you may know this if it always turns to
bitcoin by the way in gene's opening
remarks um on saturday taproot was
activated which implements with
something called snore signatures in
bitcoin which is going to make it much
more secure more efficient for 12 years
we've had bitcoin and we haven't had
this because of a patent which expired
right before bitcoin came out
okay
but what's more important here is what
is the empirical evidence because in my
view
if the argument is we need to infringe
property rights for this limited purpose
to make society better off where's the
evidence for this
does patented copyright do they promote
the progress of science of the useful
arts
so it was first it wasn't even a hunch
at first you know this wasn't done in
england to promote progress it was it
was done to to to uh to to bribe court
cronies to collect taxes for the king
so the english parliament never did a
study before the statute of anne in 1710
or statute of monopoly 1623 to see if
these things benefit society so we've
had 230 years
the founders didn't do a study when they
put it in the constitution
okay
so
it's been 230 years where's the evidence
where's the proof
so
back in the 1800s there was a growing
reaction against patenting copyright law
by free-market economists who were
wondering what the hell are we doing
limiting limiting trade and
limiting competition
and in response because they were being
attacked by free market defenders uh the
defenders came up with a term like
intellectual property to make it sound
like these are natural property rights
but they're not
now the first big empirical study was in
the fifties the austrian economist fritz
maklup who actually did his phd under
mises
in 1958 after commissioned by congress
to do the study concluded no economist
on the basis of present knowledge could
possibly state with certainty how the
patent system as it now operates confers
a net benefit or net loss on society
if we did not have a patent system it
would be irresponsible on the basis of
our present knowledge of its economic
consequences to recommend instituting
one
thousand 1958
1986 george priest an economist and
attorney a law professor in the current
state of knowledge economists know
almost nothing about the effect on
social welfare of the patent system or
of other systems of intellectual
property
wesley cohen and stephen merrill in 2003
there are theoretical as well as
empirical reasons to question whether
patent rights advance innovation in a
substantial way in most industries the
literature on the impact of patents on
innovation must be considered emergent
and then he says an economic analysis of
the costs and benefits of ip is no more
within our reach today than it was in
macklips day in the 50s
boston university law school professors
and economist mirin bisson in 2008
it seems unlikely that patents today are
an effective policy instrument to
encourage innovation overall patents
place a drag on innovation
there is clear empirical evidence that
the patent system is broken
law professor andrew torrence 2009
little empirical evidence exists to
support the assumption that the patent
system spurs innovation economist bulger
and levine in 2013 the case against
patents can be summarized briefly there
is no empirical evidence that they serve
to increase innovation and productivity
petromos or 2016 when patent rights have
been too broad or strong they actually
discourage innovation heidi williams in
2017 to summarize evidence from patent
law changes has provided little evidence
that stronger patent rights encourage
research investments
and finally in law professor thomas
ching's view theory and empirical
studies firmly refute the notion that
patent protection is necessary for
securing innovation
so
in my view
the evidence is on our side on the
patent abolition side there is no
evidence that shows that the takings
done by patents
benefit society my own estimates based
upon estimates of the cost of patent
trolling
is that patents
cost at least 100 billion dollars a year
on the economy and it's not like we're
hurting people to the tune of 100
billion dollars and then we're getting
300 billion dollars of innovation out of
it i believe we're actually getting less
innovation because
once you have a patent on a product you
have less of an incentive to keep
innovating because you can rest upon
your laurels for 17 years and your
competitors have less of an incentive to
innovate
by improving your product because if
they make an improved product they can't
sell it so i believe patents actually
discourage innovation so we're paying
100 billion dollars
and we're getting less innovation for
the bargain
so i believe it's clearly time to
abolish these monstrous regimes and i
welcome professor epstein uh refuting
what i said because then i can feel
better about uh the career choice i made
20 years 28 years ago
thank you very much
[Applause]
i do not believe in transworld trespass
i want to thank stefan
setting me up in a way let me see what i
can do in order to answer him and let me
begin in effect by reminding everybody
what the resolution was it's a rather
extreme resolution it calls for the
abolition of the system and i don't
think that you could establish the
abolition of any particular system for
any reason if what you can show is that
the system is it now exists contains
certain kinds of excesses which need not
be put there so to start with the
copyright example the so-called
copyright term extension act did give
people copyright protection for 70 years
after death it is one of the dumbest
statutes that has ever been drafted
there is no reason whatsoever to tie any
exclusive right however it may be
created to the life of the author so
that gilbert out living sullivan gets
longer protection for his part of the
thing than the other uh but the question
is can you make the same argument about
a statute which has a 14-year term and a
14-year extension with respect to
original work and that's going to be a
much more difficult kind of thing to do
it's certainly correct if you talk about
copyrights and the kind of statutory
damages that are given that in many
cases are absurdly high because they
bear no relationship to real losses but
it doesn't matter that a regime which
has been tempered a little bit is going
to have those difficulties it says that
sometimes what you do is you issue
injunctions that shut down very useful
situations but it doesn't fall from that
that you can't put together a rather
effective regime for either copyrights
on the one hand or patents on the other
which gives limited injunctions and
conditions them in various kinds of ways
so as permit the uses that are truly
necessary with respect to the patented
or copyrighted technology while avoiding
wholesale exploitation so what you have
to do is to figure out from principles
as to whether or not you want this thing
and why do you want
well what we're told by steph is that if
you look at the world what you will see
is that it's a system of natural rights
is one that we protect and a system of
copyrights and patents given the fact
that they're always going to be created
by some kind of statutory authorization
offend the system of natural rights if
you go back and you start doing the
classical history on all of this stuff
what you find out is that many people
made exactly the same arguments
associated with having property rights
and land acquired by first possession
so if you want to go back to the prudent
type of theories what they said is the
moment somebody takes a piece of land
puts a fence around it and claim it to
his what happens he has now prevented
the rights of other people to move
various places across the face of the
earth and so therefore a system of
private property is necessarily unjust
because of the way in which it takes the
normal rights of mobility
i was trained in roman law and what i
discovered is amazingly enough these
yokels managed to get it exactly right
when they said there's certain kinds of
resources that should be left in common
rivers and beaches and so forth because
the pulled out problem was too great but
there are other kinds of resources
mainly land shadows animals and so forth
in which private property rights are
going to be necessary even if you take
things out of the nature because what
happens is the incentive to create and
to develop these things is only going to
exist if you have exclusive rights to
them this started off as an agricultural
metaphor most famously in the expression
uh those only people who ought to be
able to reap for those who sew and if in
fact you had only common land nobody
would ever be able to plant anything
because somebody else would be able to
snatch it away and when you start
dealing with various kinds of
intellectual property you have exactly
the same kind of distribution there are
in all systems of natural property
things which cannot be reduced to
private possession uh by any form of
grant or administrative application
application these are generally called
abstract ideas and natural elements the
two main categories and the theory is
you try to run a world in which you
could patent or copyright the
pythagorean theorem it means that
anybody who wants to do a proof for the
next 20 years is going to have to pay
him they're going to be thousands of
theorems that you have to buy and the
whole thing will break down and so what
you do is you say these things are held
in common and you give a system of
prizes or rewards or something if you
try to stimulate that stuff but if
you're then starting to talk about
various things that could be made using
these mathematical theorems algorithms
for the designs of various medicines and
things of that particular sort all of a
sudden the dynamics start to change if
you decide that you're going to leave
these things in the public domain no
matter how much work's put in you get
the following kind of fatal
disequilibrium which is going to really
hurt innovation i spend a billion
dollars to develop a brand new drug i
get no protection for it somebody else
can figure out what the formula is quite
easily by reverse engineering i have to
recover my fixed cost when i try to sell
this stuff this particular fellow
doesn't have any fixed cost and so what
he can do is outsell me in the
marketplace i understand this going in
and once i understand that i don't
engage in the kind of investment you're
talking about
a step is quite right to say oh you want
to look around and you can do things by
trade secrets and that is certainly a
dominant mode with respect to formula
and various kinds of processes but if
you're trying to sell a drug and so
forth that can be easily reversed
engineered you've got to have a patent
system and so the way in which the
intellectual property space is organized
you have things that are kept in the
common domain you have things that
become trade secrets you have things
that become copyrighted and patented and
all of these things if they work
together are going to create some kind
of greater efficiency now i've heard
that there's no empirical evidence that
supports this particular position but i
think on balance it's probably not the
case if you start looking at this one of
the things that i would refer to is a
well-known statue called the bai dole
statute which was introduced back in
1980 and by dole had the following
proposition it said the government gave
lots of money to various universities in
order to sponsor research and the theory
was that you now have something which is
sponsored by the government and the
government could say that as the
condition of its particular grant it
wants you to leave this stuff in the
public domain so that anybody can use it
in whatever way shape or form that they
happen to see fit
and if you go back to a famous book by
vanderbilt bush called the science the
endless frontier back in 1945 at the
beginning of the period of american
dominance in science and research on
what he said is he wanted the following
kind of patent regime he wanted to make
sure that when you were working with
things up to the proof of principle that
is general arguments about how various
things in nature start to work nobody
ought to be able to get a patent on that
but when it came to talking about
compositions of matters for example
particular kinds of drugs or various
kinds of processes with industrial
application at that particular point he
encouraged people to patent these things
because of the incentive effects that it
had and that they would hope that they
would give the government a license to
use them free of charge itself a rather
tricky situation well the question is
can we figure out whether this is a good
or a bad thing with my goal the general
rule was that stuff was left into the
public domain and so therefore without
patents and without any copyright
protection uh what you should be able to
say is aha we're going to get an
enormous amount of innovation coming out
of this stuff but in fact they found
exactly the opposite they found out that
there were many labs that had all sorts
of very clever techniques but when it
came to commercialization nobody was
prepared to commercialize something even
though it was left in the public domain
and so what the statute said under these
circumstances is that we are now going
to create a device to incentivize people
to privatize the stuff and depend and so
the way the system started to work is
that you work with a university on a
government grant and then the school
makes an elaborate kind of contract the
author gets a certain percentage the
department gets a certain percentage the
university itself gets a certain
protection and all of a sudden out of
nothing you see all sorts of research
arms developing in universities the sole
purpose of which is to market these
kinds of patents into various kinds of
spaces and the question is well why is
it that they want this kind of
protection and it's a kind of a subtle
argument because the empirics were very
clear there was a massive growth in
innovation that took place in the early
80s in response to this kind of
development and the attitude i think
most people had is if this thing is out
there and it's not being protected by
patent we have no idea who our
competitors are going to be they're
going to be so many of them in so many
different directions that it has a very
substantial chance that if we develop
this stuff there's going to be somebody
else who's going to try to sell the same
thing they're going to be too many
people who are coming in they'll compete
the price down to zero and none of us
will be able to recover the fixed cost
associated with the operation and
development of our patent on the other
hand once you start to give patent kinds
of protection it's very important
because it changes the game now that you
have this particular kind of protection
what you do is you have an exclusive
right to the invention that comes there
it may well be that you're going to get
competition from somebody who has a
different device and a different patent
but you don't have to worry about the
added risk that the particular
technology that you're trying to develop
through the patented resource is going
to be the thinking that's going to be
misappropriated and taken by somebody
else and so what happens is now you
start to see people really springing to
action and the level of increase in
various industries that have taken place
was nothing short of spectacular in
virtue of this particular situation uh
innovation now became institutionalized
proof of principle was left in the
university and the development of
various kinds of goods and so forth was
taken and put together in this other
kind of system and now when you start
looking at this the question is how do
you describe these things and here it's
very important to draw an intellectual
distinction
between two ways of thinking of the
patent system or the copyright system
those people who think about this system
in a hostile fashion almost always call
it a system of monopoly power those
people who think about it in a more
positive light as i tend to do as a
classical liberal but not a hard-line
libertarian we tend to call them
exclusive rights what's the differences
between the two of them well every
system of private property has to have a
system of exclusive rides so i happen to
own unit 8e in my uh particular building
on central park west actually i don't
know what the university does um it's
there and lots of people who own their
own homes they have a monopoly as it
were over their own house but when you
look at a real estate market everybody
calls this market highly competitive
even though there may be no two houses
that are identical if only because
they're all each of them is located in a
different place from the other but
they're close enough substitutes that an
organized markets with brokers and
intermediates take place and nobody
would want to say that the guy owns 430
walker drive in los angeles has a
monopoly over that particular property
given everything else that is done so
essentially the creation of a system of
exclusive rights with respect to land is
an absolute prerequisite for trying to
create a competitive market what you
have to do is to have strong exclusive
rights and then there have to be enough
close substitutes out there so that you
do not want to call this thing a
monopoly
so for example you compare the system of
private property that i'm just talking
about with the system of common carriers
where it turns out there's only one
carrier that can take you in 1400 let us
say from oxford to london this fellow is
under a duty to serve because he does
have a monopoly position he's entitled
to get rent revenue and what you then do
is develop a very different kind of
system than you have with competitive
markets namely there's a system in which
rate regulation is going to be
permissible and you're trying to dance
between cilla and charybdis figuring out
how this guy can charge enough to cover
his cost and make a reasonable profit
but making sure that he doesn't engage
in a form of monopoly exactly those
sorts of risks simply do not exist when
you start dealing with ordinary people
now when you start coming with respect
to drugs and chemicals and largeness and
so forth it's exactly the same thing i
may have a monopoly writing my new book
on shakespeare but there are other
people who could write other books on
the same topic and so you start looking
under s in the bookstore you'll find 50
or 100 books all which are in
competition with one another if you
start trying to say well i really need
to have some kind of a drug to control
my high rate of cholesterol well you
could find a number of drugs that do
this all which are in competition with
one another and so what happens is the
competition between these drugs drives
the prices down it's also the case that
when you think about this particularly
in the patent space the way the system
is organized there is now an enormous
incentive on the part of people to
piggyback off of everybody else so one
of the important features of a patent
system is what it does is it requires
you to make a full disclosure of the
various methods that you have used in
order to develop the particular device
in question and to give a complete
specification of the product design now
why are you required to do that well for
one thing what it does is now somebody
reads this two things happen they can
use this and then they could try to
develop complementary products or they
can try to develop substitute products
the complementary products are one that
you want to put into place and to deal
with the first god and the substitute
comes back on the other side to give you
a competitive mark
it turns out there's a very nice work by
jonathan barnett who says as follows if
it turns out you're a big company you
really don't care as much about patent
protection because you can internalize
things through contracts and trade
secrets but he says it has ample
evidence empirically to show the point
that if in fact you're a small gun you
want patent protection because the
network of contracts that a large firm
has is not available to you so contrary
to the conventional wisdom which sort of
things that big guys muscle out little
guys the actual empirics of the
situation goes in the other direction
the little guy is the one who needs the
patent protection because he can't
resort on the other contractual network
and these guys come in and if they're
pioneers in a new area they're going to
get extraordinarily high rates of return
because they will be quote unquote of
monopolist for a short period of time
but the system of disclosures and the
narrow limitations on the patent mean
that other entrants can come in and try
to fill the same space because you're
only allowed to patent your device or
your medicine you're not allowed to
patent or protect yourself with respect
to the way in which you um uh have a
particular end so if you have something
like celebrex is the drug you can't use
beta-cox drugs or whatever the hell
they're called um and blend everybody
else from putting a rival and what you
do is you develop a competitive market
out of these things now it turns out
this is a competitive market that is
given to you for a reason the reason is
to create this innovation and when they
found out for example with respect to
the hatch waxman act in 1984
that if in fact you had to get a patent
before you applied to the fda for drug
approval that your patent term would
essentially run before you could get the
drug to market and the patent would
become worthless and so what they did is
they passed another adjustment which
essentially extended at that time for
five years the patent for a long enough
period so you could go through at the
time the fda process and still have the
full term unfortunately the fda no
surprise has become more complicated and
the hatch waxman offsets have become
somewhat inefficient but this was again
clearly market driven everybody said you
know it cost me 1.2 billion dollars to
make a drug and if the only thing i can
do with this drug is to do it under
these circumstances i won't get any
return from it
so when you look at all these systems
what's going on is you're talking about
a copyright bargain you're talking about
a patent market you're talking about
situations where the folks who come in
and get this particular protection have
to supply something in exchange for it
and then just to make sure that it works
really well what you make sure is that
these patents and these copyrights are
for limited terms they're much too long
today on the copyright space probably
too short today with respect to the
patent debates particularly with respect
to pharmaceuticals and when you do that
the things then go into the public
domain because having given the
incentive to create for a long enough
period of time now allowing a drug that
has already been created to be used at
zero price is going to have reasonably
desirable effects because you no longer
have to worry about the problem of how
you're going to create the darn thing
it's already been created and so you
could try to reduce the level which is
done and so there is now another
additional source of competition which
is that off copyright drugs and off
copyright patents and so forth all of
these things can be in competition which
things are created the other way the
system looks a little bit messy but it
really in fact works amazingly well at
least if you get rid of some of the
distortions and errors that are
associated with this application and
this is violently different and i'll end
on this point than some of the practice
that you had in england or where the
patent system was worth is because it
was so expensive to use that nobody
could rely upon it and where it was also
so corrupt that these things were given
not in exchange for a new invention they
were given to people simply to allow
them to raise revenue which they could
then kick back to the crown so the
useful invention requirements associated
with the patent clause are designed to
get rid of all of that stuff and when
you do get rid of that stuff the current
system with all that schwartz is better
than no system at all and it could be
made a lot better if in fact we prune
away the excesses and basically return
to the theory of patents and copyrights
that animate the original design of the
system thank you
thank you richard
five minutes of rebuttal if you would
like to take the lectern
i'm sad to say i'm still a little bit
depressed about my career choice
um
slightly technical matter gene i mean
professor epstein um i'm um i'm familiar
with the patent bargain refers to the
idea that the patent law grants an
exclusive right to an inventor
in exchange for him disclosing
everything
okay so that's to overcome the practice
of people using trade secrets where they
kept things secret so that's the patent
bargain i've i've never heard of a
copyright bargain so i don't know i look
forward to reading up about that um
i never claim that patents grant
monopolies but they are called monopoly
privilege grants and the entire and the
supreme court actually refers to them as
monopoly privilege grants just in a case
last year um
and the purpose as you say is to allow
these drug companies to recoup their
cost how they're going to recoup their
costs that they can't sell it for a
higher price than they otherwise could i
mean sometimes that's called a monopoly
price doesn't mean that they get a
monopoly that would classify as a
monopoly under the anti-trust laws which
have a different standard
than economists do
um as for the idea that payments help
the little guy that patents help the
little guy first of all most patents are
owned by employers not the little guy
who's the inventor who invented it okay
so it's almost it's almost always owned
by the employer
and as for helping small companies and
not big companies i think is exactly the
opposite
um what happens is you have large
companies amass huge patent treasure
troves
uh for as a good example this was the
recent smartphone patent wars about
seven or eight years ago between apple
and samsung and motorola
and they all you know apple suing
because
someone else had a smartphone with a
touchscreen and rounded corners because
they had a patent on that and and then
they're being countersued
what you what you do is if you're a
large company you have tens of thousands
of patents which you've paid lawyers
like me to get for you right and you
didn't reward your inventors for
and when someone sues you for a patent
infringement you look you look through
your pile of patents and you suit you
countersued them for some so the patent
lawsuits go on for five years
uh
and they finally settle with each other
and they grant across license and in the
meantime little companies are left out
in the coal because if they tried to
enter this fray they'd be sued into
oblivion because they don't have ten
thousand patents to go after the large
companies with so patents of course help
the big companies and they basically
help form cartels and oligopolies which
is not surprising because they are
monopoly grants of privilege
as for pharmaceuticals um
the idea first of all anyone who's
interested you can't do this while we're
debating but you should read chapter
nine of bolger and levine's book against
intellectual monopoly they completely
explode all the myths about the
pharmaceutical industry needing patents
and being requiring patents
so let's take covet as an example right
now there's 11 different vaccines that
have been approved for emergency use
somewhere in the world and as december
as of december 2020 last year there were
over 200 vaccine candidates of covet
being developed and at least 52 were in
clinical or human trials so there's lots
of innovation going on and modern on
october 20 waived its patent rights so
if it needs a patent to recoup its cost
why did it waive its patent rights look
italy and switzerland didn't even have
drug patents until the late 70s and they
were some of the leading uh
creators of drugs
um if just as an example boulder and
levine they did a study they looked to a
poll
uh at the british medical journal's
readers on the top medical milestones in
history they found that almost none of
them had anything to do with patents
penicillin x-rays tissue culture and
aesthetics
uh chlorprom i can't read that one
public sanitation germ theory
evidence-based medicine vaccines birth
control pill computers oral
oral rehydration therapy dna structure
monoclonal antibody technology and the
discovery of the health risk of smoking
of the top 15 injuries only two had
anything to do with patents and the
center for disease control in the u.s
they had a list of the top 10 public
health achievements of the 20th century
none of them had anything to do with
patents a review of the even review of
the most important pharmaceuticals
reveals that many came about without the
motive or the possibility of acquiring a
patent including like aspirin azt
cyclosporine digoxin ether fluoride
insulin medical marijuana methadone
morphine oxytocin penicillin
phenobarbital processol quinine ritalin
solver sand vaccines and vitamins so you
don't need patents to develop drugs
thanks
five five minutes without
let me
start with the the first point that he
raised about the question about
employers in large firms and domination
there is a key distinction between small
firms that have employees and large
firms that have employees in both of
these cases the patent is always filed
for by the particular inventor and
they're assigned over to the firm but
they're going to be assigned in very
different ways to large firms into small
firms and one of the things that we now
discover is that to the extent that
patent rights turn out to be weak the
small firm no longer could be confident
that it can get injunctive relief
against a large firm that blizzards it
with respect to suits and so they can be
put into difficulty if in fact when you
started to have a patent and you knew
that it was protected you're not going
to be suffered by the particular
difficulties at hand the second thing to
understand about all of these things is
that
the so-called monopoly risk associated
with these patents and the coordination
problem is handled in other ways one of
the most important institutions
associated with patent is the system of
licensing this can work in many
different ways sometimes it's one person
just gives a license to another person
to use it on a non-exclusive basis and
then what happens is you can get this
out to many other people and it's the
exact same method that you use with
respect to trade secrets only you don't
have quite the same confidentiality
problem but the more important
development with respect to these
various licenses is one which allows you
to have licensed pools of one kind or
another in order to develop various
kinds of technology so you take
something like telecommunications where
the particular cost of transmitting and
collecting various kinds of information
has dropped exponentially for the last
40 or so years what you discover in fact
is that these things are all organized
by very latin patent pools they have all
sorts of rules which tell them how it is
that you're going to figure out what you
put inside the particular standard how
it is you enter into agreements with
various companies so that they restrict
their monopoly price if in fact one of
their elements is in the standard it
turns out that the number of companies
that you now need as the patents become
or the products become more toxic
increases and yet the continued rate of
decline in prices has all been driven by
the ability of these licensing
arrangements to start to work to create
these kinds of standards you would never
get these devices to begin with if you
didn't have a patent system and in
addition to that you would never be able
to get the coordination without the
licenses to understand how this system
particularly works what you have to do
is to understand that when you're
dealing with real estate and other kinds
of situation if you give people as a
property right only the exclusive right
to use something and you don't give them
the right to enter into various leases
or mortgages or gifts or other kinds of
transactions are they going to be
relatively useless and the patent system
essentially overcomes the holdout
problem that you get by having an
extremely developed institutional set of
arrangements which works in this
particular fashion and when it comes to
the invention it's important to
understand that there's a distinction
many of these drugs were discovered in
earlier and simpler times where it turns
out that you didn't have the kind of
massive development costs that are
associated today but even then it may be
that the device wasn't discovered
through a patent system but its
marketing in fact probably did require
some kind of additives or other stuff
which may well have been protected by
patent and so the question you have to
ask is whether or not the unprotected
stuff will make it into the marketplace
faster than it will with some degree of
protection and i didn't hear any
response to the statements associated
with buy dole which took a situation
where everything was in fact in the
public domain and found that it did not
work particularly well and there was an
enormous uptake in the number of drugs
if you're trying to figure out what it
is that blocks a
innovation it's the same kind of
standard regulatory arguments that all
libertarians and classical liberal makes
it's essentially something like the fda
which comes along and in the name of
safety and effectiveness imposes
requirements that keep drugs off the
market for so long that it turns out
that their healthy qualities are not
going to be exploited and they're all
too many cases of drugs that are left on
the market only after years when in fact
if they had been introduced earlier they
would have produced the same benefits 10
years before in 10 years longer than it
otherwise had been the case so putting
this whole system together
the question is not whether you can find
devices that can be developed without
patents in one form or another the
question is do the patents add to that
we were mentioned about moderner and
other kinds of companies that do this
the point to remember is you may not
need patent protection if you're going
to get tens of billions of dollars of
payment guaranteed by the company the
government for the property that you
create because if in fact you have a
guaranteed buyer of the particular
situation all the incentive problems
aren't there the issue you have to worry
about in all those cases is whether or
not the government is paying too much
and it may well be if you ran a patent
system you could actually get the things
for less total cost after you subtract
out the tax subsidies and put in the
case the cotton protection so it's much
more complicated i think than stefan has
said thank you
[Applause]
uh thank you both uh we now go to the q
a portion of the evening uh and uh as uh
you know in in this particular case
we're gonna give either of you the
option at any time to ask the other a
question uh
would one of you richard or stefan would
you want to exercise that that option
now oh
wait for the question first do you want
you want to waive the uh opportunity or
do you want to ask richard a question
uh he wants to ask you a question
richard fired yeah go ahead okay so
professor epstein uh
you you seem to believe with me that 130
years or so for copyright is absolutely
absurd and ridiculous
now
apparently if you have a copyright
system that's what happens
so
would you prefer to have no
patents or 130 i mean sorry a zero
copyright term or 130 years if that was
your choice
one of these alternatives because most
of the value with respect to any liberty
any literary work most of it for most of
them are going to be concentrated in the
first 10 or 15 years so essentially the
distortions that are completed from the
years 20 to 120 may matter with respect
to mickey mouse and a few other things
like that but with most things it turns
out it doesn't and remember it's not
just books and literature that are
subject to copyright a software is
subject to a complicated regime but it's
often protected by copyright and the
useful life of a software copyrighted
device is sort of five ten years at most
usually less than that and so
essentially i think that the overage is
harmful but i think the most important
years of the in years not the out years
and so i would keep the system and i
would do everything at my power to get
rid of the silliness all of which was
introduced by international agreements
because i think what i would answer is
i'm talking about an ideal patent system
which doesn't have the terrible risk
that are associated with the public
choice dimension that we have in the
current law where the ability to take
things out of the comments and to put
them into these things are completely up
to legislative discretion there was in
fact as i tried to make in one of these
cases that were brought early on
that if something is already in the
public domain to put it back and to say
it's now going to receive copyright
protection of patent protection is just
crazy and the culprit there is the
constitutional system which is so weak
that what it says is we use a rational
basis test which in my takings book i
attack and allow them to be reprotected
um and this was the case that larry
lessig argued in 2003 somehow the name
seems to escape me but i thought that it
was exactly right uh to say that if you
want to extend it for no quid pro quo
whatsoever which is what they did with
the term extension act that should be
unconstitutional so again i think the
simplest way to put the point is i'm
trying to defend a ideal system not the
current system and the only way you
could get to that system paradoxically
is to do what i wanted to do in the
takings book uh which is to create a
strong and stable system of property
rights which would also mean that things
that have been put into the public
domain will be kept there um yeah i want
to inform the microphone is over there
and so please if you want to answer ask
uh a question of either one please line
up at the mic uh and uh uh so uh do so
uh with that microphone over there um
and uh i i wanted
i wanted to ask uh uh exercise a
moderator's prerogative to also ask
richard a question
i guess pertaining to the similar one
where uh you uh
there seems to be a a notion on your
part that that uh that when you give
government power it won't abuse it i
mean that that's an accusation where
obviously in
eminent domain for example notoriously
you defend eminent domain but you're
saying oh well donald trump exercising
eminent domain in atlantic city you know
that's not an inevitable part of the
system that that when you allow
government
to exercise these actions that the crony
capitalist and the corruption won't take
over and that therefore it's uh we can
always imagine an ideal system have you
heard that kind of complaint before to
your view and what do you say in
response to it say that i have not heard
it would commit gross perjury on my part
it is i think in fact the central
objection that you made that has been
made to my system about eminent domain
said the problem about you richard is
you prefer he'll have corrupt judges
doing this stuff and i prefer to have
corrupt legislatures my answer is
in effort to try to stop the corruption
on both sides i want to aid to divide
the powers and b to resort to a title
which i'm now associated with simple
rules for this complex world that will
start to delineate when it is that the
government can and cannot take and so
what happens is uh you see the errors
going both ways there's a case called um
monsanto and what they did is they had a
series of devices that would pay trade
secreted and they had to essentially get
government approval for their use and
the government tried to condition their
approval of the thing on the grounds
that they allow other people to use it
for a license fee that was either zero
or set by the government and my view was
that if you're doing things for health
and safety you're not allowed to under
the doctrine of unconstitutional
conditions uh to permit somebody in the
government to give it to your arrival
for at something below market cost so
that's the trade secret system and steve
you know steph's in favor of that and
you have exactly the same time of
corruption that could exist there my
view about this is i spent my life
trying to argue for a system of coherent
property rights and just compensation
and limited public use to control those
particular public choice problems have i
been successful
i think that question answers itself but
it's not because the system has been
tried and failed it's because it's never
been tried at all particularly after a
famous case called penn central which
says there's a rapid distinction between
a regulations quote on quote on the one
hand and takings of property on the
other and the government rolls over and
dies with respect to regulation so
zoning and all sorts of air rights are
now at risk and i think the answer is we
don't want to mess around with the
intellectual property system which works
very well between private parties by and
large although there are obviously huge
cases of error but what you want to do
is to make sure that the government can
corrupt it by taking these rights and
giving them to somebody else so uh the
culprit in all of these endeavors is in
fact a weak and indefinite system of
property rights sponsored by the courts
who are essentially give up on their
constitutional function and by the way
they do it with land zoning laws are a
classic illustration of gigantic
government over speech with respect to
use because they don't follow the common
law prescriptions on zoning and
reciprocal covenants but allow huge
wealth transfers to take place so this
is a problem endemic across the entire
system and you don't you know and you
don't think that the endemic and nature
of it is what you're up against richard
that that's it but it is if you grant
them and it is when you don't grant them
the government is essentially a
promiscuous beast you put any system of
rights together whether it's a good or
bad one and they have the infinite
capacity if left to their own devices to
make it worse
and so what i'm trying to say quite
simply is you have to attack the monster
at the other end what you have to do and
the reason i wrote the takings book was
you have to stop the rent seeking which
of course is exactly what we both agree
on and what happens is you have a bunch
of courts out there who believe that all
government agents in the legislature are
well intentioned in what they do and so
they defer to what it is that they want
to say and if you're going to get a
regime of judicial um deference no
matter what the system of property
rights you start with you're going to
end up with something that's truly
horrible and so either you tighten up
the constitutional system or we're going
to have to fight it through uh and
sometimes you'll be better in the 80s we
actually had a bit more sense on this uh
you've come to abide then you come to
obama and you'll come to everybody
afterwards and it's been pretty much
downhill since that time and it will
continue to be so unless there's a
fundamental change and on that issue uh
constitutional limitations on the
government to confiscate i think we're
at one i mean i've spoken too long but i
think we're at one you guys agree the
government is a [ __ ] as richard just
said i didn't say that i said the
government is a ransom
i
you said it's a promiscuous beast but uh
i bet yes but anyway um
do you want to come just a quick comment
uh i actually would abolish trade secret
law too but that's a different argument
but uh
isn't it it's a little ironic that i
believe you have argued correct me if
i'm wrong you've argued that you're
you think there might be some use for
any trust law but generally you would
oppose it because it's going to be
abused so let's say no no no no no no i
can send you the quote okay let me okay
you guys are talking about the trust now
it's a little bit off topic but anyway
but if you want to say something that's
the one sentence answer
is the ques the only area in which
antitrust law seems to work at all well
is with respect to horizontal
arrangements and the big uncertainty is
whether you render those unenforceable
or put the sherman act behind it and the
actual history of this stuff started
very badly uh but i think it got a
little bit better so by the time you got
to the 1990s it was a terrible body of
law you're seeing systematic decline
coming back again my former student amy
klobush has put forward a bill to end
that's a richard epstein's sentence
thank you very much for that richard
epstein sentence and uh uh
question and a question uh uh going
don't have to identify yourself laying
on these guys who do you want to ask the
question of go ahead hi my my question
is for stephen and i i came to this
debate stephan uh stefan uh uh
inclined to try to
to be sympathetic to your view but i i
and then i heard the debate and the
debate's more about efficiency and and
what produces the greatest amount of
wealth and things like that and i i
wonder how you are how you answer the
argument that doesn't it seem
fair that if somebody writes a two or
three hundred page book and tries to
sell it for twenty dollars
a copy
that there ought to not be that that it
ought to be prohibited that for some
period of time that person not have a
competitor who can say well i'll sell it
for 10 because hey i have a copier and
and what the heck and and so that there
is a moral element other than just an
economic element and i i wonder how you
how you meet that i i i don't think it's
fair uh i think that if you choose to
make information public then you can't
complain if people copy it period
that's the principled argument
and not only that there are ways to make
money
creators find ways to make money off of
novels for example uh you know i've
pointed out you take the harry potter
example uh jk rowling writes harry
potter um
she wrote she writes it on a train
because she has a passion
let's say she sold it on amazon for 99
cents and she got a million fans and
then she was knocked off the next day so
then her profits tail it off right away
okay so now she writes the sequel and
she she tells her fans i'm gonna publish
this as soon as i get you know five
million people give me five dollars and
then there's a movie made and they
consult with her they pay they pay her
some of the ticket box office because
she's going to be a consultant and this
is the legitimate movie not all the
other knock-offs that are coming out she
could have still been a very wealthy
woman so people can find ways to profit
off of their uh off of their artistic
creativity but i think if you reveal
information to the public just like if
you sell a product
which pleases customers you're choosing
to make your new invention public and if
people compete with you no i'm a
libertarian i believe in the free market
i think competition is good and i think
learning is good
well i think
more competition between harry potter
and some other book rather than having
knockoff sell for the price of originals
um you can use ingenious schemes to
overcome some of these difficulties but
the revenues you could get from those
schemes are far less so you put the
scheme together and say i'll put this
thing public the moment i get a thousand
readers each to pay me five dollars okay
you do very fine on that then the book
turns out to be a hit and the next
generation there are a million people
who repay nothing but the marginal cost
the productions are going to clearly go
down with respect to that
and i don't think there's any particular
social reason to do that to put it
another way the problem about
libertarianism it has the first correct
move which says the prohibition against
the use in force and fraud is an
improvement over the license to do
everything in the state of nature and so
what really happens is there's a
consequentialist argument given what we
know about human beings
given that we know what we know about
human beings can we create pareto
improvements by changing legal system
without cash transfers and the argument
in favor of patent and copyrights is we
could do exactly the same thing in areas
where physical possession does not give
you adequate control and so we do that
we give you the right and then we try to
limit it so what is a powerful right
does not become a complete monster and
they're always you know what does a
derivative work there's a lot of abuse
on that uh but abe's irish rose was not
a derivative work of whatever it was
that somebody said it was and so on it
goes get good judges you could control
it and the issue is where you're going
to get more abuse and i think in effect
an open regime with contract gimmicks
won't do it nearly as well as a
copyright regime and what you then have
to do is to try to make sure that it
doesn't go off the rail so the criminal
answer is we do recognize these things
and then what we try to do is to figure
out where the abuses are and pose
something to do it and you know for many
years these technical committees that
worked on patents and copyright really
did it the work that was done for the
1952 patent right by guiles diction and
federico i mean these guys were geniuses
and they did it with two guys they sat
around the kitchen table and they did a
much better job on this than the well i
would ask you the question do you prefer
the 1952 act to the american invents act
i think the american events act only
made trivial changes to patent law
yeah only trivial changes
the whole system is basically the same
well i hope you're right
uh one quick
point to make uh following up on that if
you think about it copyright is
basically dead already because the
internet's the world's biggest copying
machine and thank god for that so
encryption file torrenting you know you
can go get the next harry potter book
the next day you can get music movies
it's rampant
so basically copyright is dead and do we
see a reduction in the supply of
artistic creations today we probably
have more books being printed and
published every year than in the history
of mankind so the idea that copyright
without copyright we wouldn't have
artistic creation is obviously absurd
because it's happening right now yeah on
the other hand uh when you have these
various books that command these
enormous advances right it's because
essentially there's a belief that there
is some exclusive right even though
there's going to be some leakage
associated with it and people take
enormous steps in order to make sure
that these kinks cannot be distributed
in an illicit fashion clearly you have
to worry about that when you put the
system together but because it's a worry
doesn't mean that you want to say if a
system is now 60 effective drive it down
to zero uh what you do is you keep it at
the 60 and you recognize the leakage and
you know to answer what steph says for
example and the next thing is yes i mean
you're a great artist and people start
stealing your stuff so the record
business goes you do recover some of it
by going on tour right um on the other
hand after you reach 40 you don't like
going on tour anymore and if it turns
out it's your back issues rather than
your new issues going on tour is not
going to do it for you at that point so
these are very imperfect substitutes and
it turns out that the protection does
induce the production
in all of these industries
how you release them on movies and
netflix and so forth all of that system
is still driven by copyright
uh question
thank you our speakers for coming out my
question is for uh professor epstein um
you mentioned
uh mickey mouse and and how most uh most
inventions have some kind of natural
death that occurs
whereas mickey mouse has lasted forever
but you also mentioned um
how uh corollary to private property uh
whereby um you have exclusive rights to
those forever why isn't
why why shouldn't mickey mouse last
forever with rights to to the original
owner or to the corporation why should
the the expiration change and how is
that different from private property
okay i think that's great i'm attacked
on both sides now so i feel extremely
comfortable
one person says for god's sake epstein
you don't want any of this system and
the other says if land rights are
perpetual why isn't the same thing true
with respect to copyrights and patents
well the explanation is i think best
understood by comparing both of these
things to something known as a trademark
and a trademark is in fact a form of
intellectual property and it's a form
that lasts forever because what it is
it's a beacon that warrants to this
potential user that you can be
associated with the reputation of the
party so that if the people start to
chisel on the thing you're going to be
hurt because your brand's going to be
compromised and i think that's a very
good system but the copyright system
doesn't have that reputational signaling
function and what you want to do is to
say there are two goods that you have
one of them is if you put this thing
into the public domain since it's a
thing that could be non-rivals and
reproduced every time you get a large
number of people who could use it for
zero and that's a good
but if you do that at the beginning you
don't get the thing so it's a balance
and what you're trying to do is to
figure out how long of protection do you
have to give to induce the production at
a satisfactory level given what i said
before the out years are much less
important with respect to the production
than the early years and so there after
you put it into the public domain
it turns out that the thing continued to
be used take land and you own it for a
hundred years and then you put it into
the public domain the whole thing is
going to become an absolute mess because
i can't farm if you're going to farm and
so forth so exclusivity is needed to
make sure that land holds its value it's
not needed to make sure that patents and
copyrights are produced they're
different situations and if you're
trying to think of this as a kind of a
sort of social engineering based on
empirical hunches some of these hunches
are better than others and this one
seems to work and the question then is
how long and nobody in his right mind
would say 115 years is necessary to
induce the production uh the 24
the 1428 was probably pretty good most
people on drugs if you know their
profile understand that good drugs
actually become more valuable in many
cases towards the end of their term
rather than less because they now have a
history of use which means that the side
effects are understood so in the last
year of a cholesterol drug going out
there it may have its highest level of
sale so if you knock that down from 10
to from from 12 to 10 that's a huge
difference and generally speaking i
think what you want to do is to extend
those a little bit longer modify hatch
waxman and then as these things become
generic they place the necessary price
constraint on the next guy who has to
make an improvement large enough to
justify the premium and the research
costs that he has to put together so i
think they're perfectly good reasons for
the way the system works if you
understand it um what you have to do is
to understand that all these things
require judgments at the margin and when
you get politicians they're not very
good at marginal judgments
uh comment from you oh yeah so i would
abolish trademark ii by the way but for
different
reasons professor epstein um
good i like it i mean you're a brave man
the the reason that you don't want
patents and copyrights last forever is
because you don't really think their
property rights which means they violate
property rights uh although you call
them property rights in your writing and
one of your arguments in the structural
unity of property intellectual property
and real property you allow analogize it
to property to normal property and you
favor injunctions because it's property
rights so you're all over the map i
believe on that but there are some
insane libertarians who do take a
principled approach a consistent
approach like submarines columbus
spooner they wanted these things to last
forever hey if it's going to be a
property right it should last forever
and if that had happened we would be
dead now the human race would have died
out because you couldn't do anything you
have to get permission from the from the
descendants of of ugg from caveman days
well that's why i don't want perpetual
rights i mean look the constitution when
they talk about limited rights they do
not mean that you could create a
copyright for a million years and say
that it's limited uh they meant this in
a much more functional way about you
know in real time how long makes sense
and the 14 28 year kind of principle is
there
the whole point here is utilitarian on
both ends
if you basically keep these things
perpetual people will in fact die off in
a terrible way because everything new
will become derivative or dependent upon
everything before and putting into the
public domain so you're trying to figure
out how it is you maximize over the long
term the sum of the incentives to create
and the sums for the incentives for
effective um dissemination i think it's
perfectly principled to do this
what it is is it introduces an element
of complexity at the middle but it's
worthwhile because if you have the zero
alternative you won't get enough of the
stuff that you want into
commercialization and if you keep it
perpetual essentially the patents and
the copyrights become strangulation
devices so what you do is you try to go
for a
transition this has always been the
history so i will put the question back
to you in the other way if everybody
who's ever worked in these fields on a
day-to-day basis believes in limited
copyright and patent protection um why
is it that the extremes are correct i
think the correct thing to do is to
figure out how it is you take that
middle and figure out how you massage it
and i don't mean this as an abstract
matter i mean i'm pretty confident that
if you were to ask serious people
there's nobody who's going to stop
wanting to have 50-year patent terms the
longest you ever hear in any discussion
is going to be 20 um and i think that
you know that's a perfectly good
compromise life is filled with
trade-offs i just want the right people
to make them which in this case means me
but he won't run for office
unfortunately uh and uh
one quick comment okay
you may not be aware of this but when
the constitution was being drafted
jefferson wasn't there but he sent a
letter i think madison proposing an
amendment to the bill of an article in
the bill of rights which would have said
the monopoly grants i think he used the
word monopoly of patent and copyright
can only be granted for x years so he
wanted to put a time limit in there it
was rejected but i wish it had it
happened well i mean my answer is if it
had been 18 months god forbid if it's
been 20 years um i would have been
comfortable with that it was a blank i
read it as a zero yeah i mean then
that's always the problem i mean a
number beats a principle that's why i
have statutes of limitations and so
forth and you could ask the same
question about that why is it if you
have a good uh situation uh to sue a
trespasser sitting on your land one year
you get a million two years you get two
million you get the 20 years you get
zero
and that's because the statute of
limitations is put in there in order to
basically make sure the security of
titles will take place and that these
disputes will resolve themselves in time
we have effort and so having limits like
that is everywhere within the law and
you have sometimes soft limits the
estoppel doctrines and sometimes they're
hard limits um and if you get them wrong
it's catastrophic a one-day statute of
limitations isn't going to cut it and a
100-year statute of limitations isn't
going to cut it either and so what
happens is it started at 40 went down to
30 now it's down to about 10 for land
and why is that because the devices for
detection are more powerful so there's
less reason to
allow for longer periods of uncertainty
um and again it's the question of
finding transitions hard transitions are
needed because you can't live in the
middle space where a patent is 60 valid
that doesn't make any sense so it's an
on off switch and the correct thing to
do is to figure out where you put that
particular switch rather than to pretend
that you don't have the pant at all or
that you don't have an on off switch
once you do have a picture next question
yeah yeah next one
uh
samuel marks harvard medical school um
i'm really convinced consular by your
argument um open source everything i
invent
new medical devices
um how do i convince my comrades so to
speak
when i figure that out i'll let you know
i've been doing this since 19 i've been
riding on this since 1995
and i just keep trying to
beat people over the head with it and
doing this hopefully tell them to watch
the video yeah um i can say i mean
there's several of these cases mayo and
alice which starts to play very
tricky games the exception is to what
counts as an uh a natural law there's
always been a convention and everybody
agrees that equals m c squared is
something you can't protect but suppose
what it is you divide make a device
which allows you to put together certain
kinds of
chemicals in a thing
this is done empirically and do you call
this thing a law of nature or do you in
fact call it a new invention and when
this thing actually came up um justice
douglas who was a very strong
anti-patent guy in the 1940s in a case
called funk basically said it was a law
of nature and giles rich and federico
they came back and said no we're moving
this to the other side of the line
because we want to have incentives to
create it and we could have all sorts of
nice stories after alice and mayo the
two cases on this which indicate in fact
that there's a serious risk of the
decline in innovation that could take
place in the medical business if you
can't protect certain kinds of
algorithms that start with natural
events and then lead to natural cures so
i'm on the other side of that i think in
fact every time i write one of these
briefs is trying to say please get rid
of these two particular kinds of cases
because if you expand the notion of
natural law to the point at which it's
currently done
you're going to get many techniques
which were introduced in profusion on
going the other way and remember
rich and federico are the two best
patent lawyers of the 20th century and
to have two guys write a statute it was
a great intellectual achievement
i agree with
staff to some extent that the
2011 act didn't change as much as it
purported to do although it did some
harm seriously with various kinds of
business method patents but what they
did is it was a zoo they had billions
upon billion dollars worth of intrigue
right and
public choice nightmares by a bunch of
guys who didn't know what they were
talking about uh question you got a
question no
yeah you you you do okay go ahead yes
okay up to the microphone this is so
civilized
yeah so i've i've always found i i love
the theoretical aspects of this debate
but it seems like we've had a solution
sitting right in front of us and that is
compulsory licensing so i would wonder
no thank you okay we're done um i've
always thought you know the way it works
in in music publishing or with uh or
performance royalties right everyone you
can play these on radio now but you
can't reproduce them you can't
theoretically wouldn't this work for any
uh any aspect of intellectual property
and i'll leave that to either one of you
no
i mean it works for askep and bmi and
and what happens is uh the first thing
to note about this system is that
they're multiple uses all of us are more
or less identical of relatively small
values so that the transactions cost to
negotiate in many cases are simply not
uh worth it but the fly that you have in
the ointment is how do you set the rate
and if it turns you set the
participation rate too high nobody's
going to do it so that's generally not
the risk inventors will always or
composers will go down but if you set
them too low there's a real risk that
this stuff will not be produced in
sufficient quantity the other key
feature about that system is for large
users it is always permissible under the
current law to negotiate a side deal
with them so that you have a customized
rate when it turns out that you have
large consumption
but if you start using for example the
compulsory license system with respect
to drugs and so forth it turns out that
they're going to be real wipeouts
associated with their particular
operation
so that what works in one area doesn't
work in the other and this is generally
the case with intellectual property the
systems of use and licensing and
exploitation are very sensitive to the
kind of intellectual property that you
have so just as a kind of empirical
verification for that it turns out that
when people work in either panzer
copyrights there's almost nobody who
does both um because it's too difficult
they work in very narrow fields so if
you're a guy who's doing it you will do
cholesterol drugs and you won't try to
do diabetes stuff because you don't know
the science well enough and they're very
different conventions of efficiency that
work in different markets both on the
licensing side and on the compulsory
license
next question i we have time for only
one final question uh the final question
or please take the mic and ask your
question
i would like to add a bit of a practical
and realistic questions
which i have missed so far a bit uh we
had that at some point in time that it
is for the small companies who benefit
most from patents even though the large
companies have the most
uh and i don't think that is a
contradiction
uh
we develop drugs
and we are a small company
and the experience is
if you don't have a patent
or only a use patent
nobody is going to talk with you that's
correct so you have no chance of ever
getting that to the market
so without a patent protection there is
no way small companies can ever
approach even a large company and get
some of their in french inventions
brought to a larger public we have a
drug to prevent children who develop
autism from becoming non-verbal
nobody was interested
until we had the patents granted
so even having just applied for a patent
is not enough nobody is interested so
how do you overcome that yes
thank you for that question we've run
out of time but you each have seven and
a half minutes uh for summary uh i
suggest stefan and richard address that
question in your summary thank you for
the question uh amen brother we now we
now go we now go to the final final part
of the uh of the evening and uh take it
uh no no take it up yeah and uh address
the question that was just sure to your
calendar
uh
in today's world we have a patent system
given that system investors want to see
your patents and large companies want to
exploit patents so of course they have
value uh if there was no patent system
people wouldn't demand that you show
them your patents
um
so it might concluding concluding
remarks let me just say if i happen to
win tonight because i've done so well in
my career because of the largest of the
system richards and professor rich
epstein's in favor of i'm going to
donate my winnings to charity
the tootsie roll we'll go to charity
um okay
we've been talking practically normally
my defense of uh of my position has been
on more principled and propertarian type
grounds
not on the utilitarian side so much
although i think the utilitarian
argument just fails because they they
haven't met their burden of proof
all the studies that i read are all the
studies that i'm aware of i'm actually
not aware of any solid reliable studies
that prove that professor epstein is
correct
you heard the quotes he didn't counter
any of those quotes
um
so the way i look at it is this i'm
going to go a little bit into archery
economics okay mises is my favorite
economist and ludwig von mises looked at
human action from his praxeological lens
which very simply means
he understands what we do as humans by
viewing us as human actors that employ
scarce resources in the world to achieve
ends or goals right this is what we do
in life
and and economic studies this but one
thing that's overlooked in all these
discussions is that
there's a second key ingredient to
successful action and that's knowledge
because if you don't have knowledge you
can't do anything and the reason that
we're so wealthy today as a society is
not because we've discovered more things
in the earth the earth's basically the
same and we're not really any smarter
than the romans it's because we've
accumulated technological knowledge over
the years
this is what's made us rich hyatt calls
it the fund of experience
now the scarce resources are things that
only one person can use at a time this
is why property rights emerge to ration
those efficiently and to let us use them
peacefully and cooperatively in trade
without having violent conflict so
property rights emerge as a response to
the scarcity of these means
but the knowledge that we have is not
scarce it can be copied freely this is
why china got rich so quickly because
they're copying some of the things that
we've done this is not a bad thing this
is a good thing this is how the human
race advances by emulating by learning
by seeing what people do to please their
customers and you compete with them to
do the same thing or something better
these are all good things
to try to apply a property rights model
to the second key ingredient to human
action which is the main source of our
wealth today is suicidal and homicidal
and in genocidal it's insane
okay
i'm going to just close with a couple of
quotes corey doctorow science fiction
writer
wrote three or four billion years ago by
some process that we don't understand
molecules began to copy themselves we
are
the distant descendants of those early
copyists
copying is in our genes we have a word
for things that don't copy dead
as for the american founders thomas
jefferson himself the first commissioner
of the patent office famously observed
that he who receives an idea from me
receives instruction from me without
listening mine as he who lights his
candle paper at mine receives light
without darkening me
and finally as the
very amazing polymath and creative
inventor himself benjamin franklin
realized
as we enjoy great advantages from the
inventions of others we should be glad
of an opportunity to serve others by any
invention of ours
and this we should do freely and
generously
so for the sake of property rights and
liberty and innovation the patent system
of the copyright system should be
abolished thank you
[Applause]
you don't have to carry that each time
oh there's two mics
basically two mics
well thank you so much let me start
answering the question about the autism
which i think is exactly on point um i'm
trying to be a very practical person
when i say that there are trade-offs
associated with these systems and that
if you give too much protection it's
going to have a negative set of
consequences if you give too little it's
also going to have that and the
situation that you talk about is exactly
the one that jonathan barnett wrote
about in his book on innovation he's
saying little inventors either they have
a copywriter they can't negotiate with
anybody and so far for the information
will remain private and if you want to
talk about debt information private
information is going to be like that or
you really want to find other ways to do
it there are other systems that you
could try to put into place one of them
is you could try to use a contractual
system to do it but you will never be
able to keep the information private and
once it leaks it's going to go out there
and even if you kept it private you
would never be able to reach the volume
of people you want
there is also an effort in many cases to
start using various kinds of prizes uh
because they don't associate themselves
with any deadweight losses in the sense
that if i give you a nobel prize or some
kind of price for making some kind of
innovation it doesn't increase the cost
to the public at large there is a recent
book on this by zarina khan
and i think she's a little bit nuts when
she says that oh we don't want to have
any prizes at all or draw that
implication but by and large prizes
essentially have very very sharp
limitations associated with their
operation one is that they're very tiny
so if you develop a cholesterol drug
like lipitor and so forth and you get 11
billion dollars in sale if the
government's going to stand up there
says well we want this thing to be
freely competed we're gonna give you a
million dollar prize to develop this
stuff it's just not going to happen you
do it for a mathematician who proves
fermat's theorem the thing is going to
be proved and you couldn't copyright it
anyhow or patent it anyhow because it's
a general idea so sure you want to have
prizes that are built into the system
but they are not going to be able to
replace the patent so you give the prize
to the first person who comes up with an
invention and there's somebody else
behind him he doesn't get the prize but
it turns out that the second iteration
is far better than the first if you had
a patent system the second guy patents
his because there's enough distance
between it and the first god and he can
then make a bloody fortune whereas the
first guy won't make anything so if
you're relying on prizes you're relying
on centralized knowledge ostensibly
either by a government party who pays
the prize or a private gun and in fact
they don't get the benefit of any kind
of information coming out of it now i
fully agree that when you're dealing
with these systems what you're doing is
you're trying to create knowledge well
the patent system and the copyright
system actually do that
you write a book which you wouldn't
otherwise have written now anybody else
can read it and whereas there are
certain reproductive limitations on it
if i have a copy of my particular book i
could let my wife read it even though
she didn't buy it because there's a very
well understood set of limitations that
people can share these books around them
what they cannot do is re-commercialize
it and go into the market at the same
level as the first guy so you're going
to get information coming out of that
particular system and the same thing if
you have to disclose best mode of
invention with respect to something for
which you patent that information is out
there and it can be used and then once
the copyright of the patent runs out
after a sensible limit of time all that
stuff goes into the public domain so
it's not as though when you start to
create these systems you're basically
denying the importance of knowledge what
you're trying to do is to figure out an
efficient deployment which takes into
account both the cost of the creation of
the knowledge and the cost associated
with its dissemination and the only way
in which you can do that is to have a
limited term of years which is the
constant point that i took and then you
have to figure out how it is you
organize this so if i when i teach
patents or copyrights what you always do
is you start worrying about the
situation of when an exclusive right
starts to become some kind of a monopoly
and if you see the latter thing then you
want to move it so for example to give
you one case is in a very gifted set of
rules this government sometimes does
something right and in the early 90s
what happened is they were trying to
figure out the rules associated with the
question of when it is that you could
put copyrights into a pool by the
patents into a pool one to another and
what they did was as follows if it turns
out that you wish to put tools that are
patents that are substitutes for one
another into a pool that's the creation
of a cartel we're not going to allow it
but if on the other hand what you do is
you want to take um
patents that are complementary to each
other in the sense that there's a
vertical integration each one leads to
the next one putting those together in a
pool will essentially eliminate what is
called the double marginalization
problem where each person essentially
having his own patent will try to
maximize the revenue on that patent so
by the time you have to go through six
or seven patents what's going to happen
is the process will be worth nothing and
the first person who saw the way in
which you put this together was none
other than that arch progressive louis
brandeis who when he put together the
united shoe deal around 1900 figured out
that by having different stages of
production put together in a single
merged company allowed you to have
better products at lower prices than you
would if you had them separately so you
want to allow that to take place so what
you do is you then figure out when you
have these patents some forms of
interaction between them are
monopolistic and some of them are
pro-competitive and this is an overtly
consequentialist theory
so just to end i was mentioned earlier
what do i think about the antitrust law
well i'm schizophrenic about the
antitrust law because frankly what
happens is it runs in both directions um
there's a recent book written which i
regard as quite bizarre by my a
colleague of chicago eric posner who
seems to think that what we have to do
is every time we see a contract of
employment we have to assume that there
is a deep conspiracy on the part of
employers who are trying to put together
some kind of monopoly situation so as to
pay their workers low wages and he says
what that means is you get all these
workers hanging around they're desperate
for getting jobs and these skillful
monopolist buyers that is monopson this
is their call will essentially only hire
a few of them then you look at the real
world a 4.9 million people quit jobs and
it doesn't seem to be a situation where
people are being shut out of the markets
to raise prices people are raising wages
desperately in order to get these back
it's a competitive kind of market so you
don't want to sweat that kind of stuff
but there are other sorts of areas in
which you can have various kinds of
dangers and in all of these markets
you're trying to figure out or which way
will work one way or another so as i
mentioned to you before there's a world
of difference between an exclusive right
on the one hand a monopoly on the other
and people who essentially work within
the more shall we say utilitarian
tradition which i surely do um basically
will say if you're going to create
exclusivity where it promotes
competition then you're in favor of it
where you create exclusivity where it
tends to frustrate competition turns out
that you're against it well how do you
figure out which is which you actually
have to know something about the subject
matter and so the basic point i think
that comes out of all of this is this a
very complicated rich body of
information that you have to be able to
assemble and coordinate if that you
start to look at it the corner solutions
of perpetual property rise and no
property rights don't work you've got to
live in the messy middle but the good
news is if you understand the theory
well enough you can make mid-level
adjustments that are worth making and
you could do so at least if you could
overcome the congenital shall we say
ignorance which is associated with our
courts in our legislature a problem that
exists under every legal regime thank
you
[Applause]
thank you both uh jane uh please open
the voting again uh if you voted once we
want you to vote again
and well let's see now um yeah uh all
patent and copyright law should be
abolished well the yes vote started at
20.37 percent
yes vote started 20
20 37
and gained to 29.63
the yes vote then picked up
9.26 percent ditch points
the yes votes picked up 9.26 that's the
number to beat
the no vote started at 44.44 and went up
to 55.56
it picked up
11.1 point i have to call this a very
close race however since richard picked
up 11 points and
stefan picked up a little over nine
points you win by 1.7 points richard
therefore the tootsie roll goes to
richard epstein
you